we have a great group and we want to
have some time for interaction we are
hosted as you know tonight by the
international relief and development
organization ird and arthur keys on my
far right is the he's not on my far
right I'm sure but anyway is the
whatever he is the president and CEO of
the ird and he founded this in 1998 and
it's very interesting correct me if I'm
wrong art but I believe that you are the
largest recipient of federal dollars for
in an NGO for relief and development and
work among the poor and among economic
development in the world is that it yes
okay and they do good work they don't
just have programs like this they really
on the ground obviously art also has had
30 years in humanitarian assistance and
domestic and international work economic
and agricultural development and he
comes by that naturally because he's a
farm boy and he has seen what it takes
to really bring in the crops I think he
is a past recipient of the yale divinity
schools William Sloane coffin award for
peace and justice and he's worked around
the world in Asia Africa Latin America
Eastern Europe the Middle East in
anywhere else you can think of and has
overseen the distribution of more than
1.75 billion dollars in humanitarian
assistance your article in reflections
are reflected as you well know on the
poor will always have and this the
rationalization that is sometimes given
not just among people of faith who read
the New Testament Scriptures but just of
the enormity of the task and we too much
to do and how can we make a difference
so though you may want to say other
things i hope you'll reflect on that a
bit for us today art keys well thank you
i'm pleased to be to the far right of
reverend Linda later who's recently
ordained so I think we should
acknowledge that being a Calvinist that
I assume that Senator Coons does have
some sins here but but I just said this
address was certainly on the path to
perfection I think it was a tremendous
powerful personal statement linking the
democracy faith and development we
appreciate that I think that the
statements about keeping the the poor
being always with you are often taken
out of context but it does not mean that
we can't make progress in reducing
poverty so I think that we certainly
have a faith mandate to care for our
neighbor it's an honor to be with this
group of panelists than the Dean
Attridge and Senator Coons so pleased
you're going to be in Africa
subcommittee I'm sure ambassador Hall
over here is going to give you some good
advice on that but I think that if I
have anything to contribute here to your
address is to say that development needs
to be done where people are at any given
time and I would kind of expand on which
your example of the women outside union
station to mean the people in conflict
zones need to have assistance and they
need to begin to be engaged on the
development agenda as soon as possible
because the development agenda also
helps them create the conditions of
peace we can't wait until piece breaks
out because we know boy a third of the
vulnerable children in the world live in
fragile societies and those societies
are in tumult in turmoil but as we see
in Egypt right now in Libya and Tunisia
these are people that really want to get
down to business and they want to start
building both a Democratic Society and a
society with economic growth with jobs
for young people and unless there's some
active engagement on the development
agenda it will be very unstable so I
think you find a nice convergence
between the biblical mandate to help
your neighbor and also the ability of
nation states to achieve some sort of
peace and security and equity in the
world my own life I my wife is from
Bosnia and I've seen how quickly and
easily civil society can break down i
would say that could happen anywhere but
it's certainly less likely to happen
where you have people participate in
this society and if we look certainly at
egypt and libya right now that turmoil
is fueled by people who were left out of
the system and exploited i think that i
would be remiss not to ask senator Coons
to lead the charge for keeping a
sensible federal budget there so you
have commitments that have to be
balanced I believe in terms of our
domestic poverty issues but also in
terms of our foreign assistance overseas
we do live in obviously the difficult
economic times but the pain needs to be
shared equitably and looking at the
long-term interest and development takes
a commitment it takes it costs money and
it also demands solidarity from people
of faith like the people in this room so
thank you for your leadership